thank you yes sir yes we are indeed with
the international Master John Donaldson
14 time uh the team captain of the U.S
Olympic team historian extraordinaire
and uh just simply a great guy John
welcome to the show tell us a bit about
what you're doing here in St Louis right
now uh well I'm going to give a talk
tomorrow evening and it's going to be on
Bobby Fischer and Boris basket it'll tie
in with the exhibition that they're
having right now at the World Chess Hall
of Fame and my theme of this talk will
be uh Bobby and Boris their similarities
and a lot of people you know would
immediately think you know Forest being
raised in the Soviet Union and Bobby
being raised in the United States that
aside from chess they really wouldn't
have much in common but but in fact
there are quite a few similarities in
their lives and so I'll be discussing
that and the staff of the World Chess
Hall of Fame they assembled a large
number of interesting photos that will
accompany the talk and that match was
actually quite influential for York
Jessica reader as well you started uh
chess you joined the chess club when the
match started as well is that correct it
is correct yes Christian I I became a
member of the Tacoma chess club
and it's a city about 30 miles south of
Seattle and it's sitting about you know
175 000 people and when I walked through
the doors of the Tacoma chess club in
the fall of 1972 they had 200 members
and the club was open you know seven
days a week and it was just hopping and
I think that I might have you know been
a continued to be a lifelong chess
player if I hadn't gone to that club but
but I do know that because I did go
there that it really it really got me
off to a great start and of course one
of the players that I quickly met up was
was Yasser who you know a little bit
younger but but you know he's from
Seattle but we saw him off in Tacoma for
tournaments tell us about the yes or is
he a good guy or not so much I mean I've
been spending the last few months around
him I'm not sure about that well I can
tell you this I've known him now for uh
just about 50 years and I think that
during that time I maybe seen him not
smile five times
that's pretty good yes sir I remember
John we played in the U.S junior
championships
and was it Walla Walla Washington uh we
were on the east side and you put my
pillow in the freezer
that was in the 1974 uh Washington State
uh junior closed and uh besides uh
Yasser Eric tangborn a future
International master was playing so by
you know the Northwest standards it was
you know two future items in one
world-class player it was a pretty
competitive tournament uh and
yaster was already so much better than
all of us and well to be fair also in
Wenatchee Washington was maybe 100
degrees that day that after he like just
killed like three of us in a row we
decided he needed we needed to cool him
off so while he was out swimming we put
all this clothing in the freezer
[Laughter]
now John you've been the team captain
for the U.S Olympic team so many uh
times what's the most difficult part of
that job you're dealing with so many
great players so many egos as well in
the team what is the most uh well I
would say this I would say that you know
obviously we've had different types of
teams we've had some teams where they
were rated like this last time and in
2018 and 16 where they're rated first or
second in the field and then we've also
had teams in the past that have been you
know rated like eighth or or ninth that
were more evenly balanced uh and I would
say the main thing is that all the
players you know need to feel feel
comfortable that they need to feel that
they're part of the team and I would say
that one thing I've been very fortunate
is that we've never really had had any
players play in those 14 olympiads that
have Captain that have been like
problematic that sort of put their
individual results over the team so it
you know for me it's it's actually made
it a pretty easy job uh but sometimes
there you know there's certain
challenges I mean this recent event in
Chennai obviously we were really hoping
for more than we achieved and I've
thought about that a lot the
the last couple months you know like
every day pretty much you know and uh
you know it it definitely you know the
the tournament was organized as I'm sure
all your viewers know on on a relatively
short notice the uh uh you know
originally was going to be in haunt him
on Sisk then it was going to be in
Moscow then the pandemic happened and
then uh they're you know it looked like
after the invasion in Ukraine that there
would be be no Olympiad and then the
Indians offered to jump in with like
four months to go and it was just uh you
know this is something that normally
takes the country a couple years to put
together I mean there's there were close
to 200 countries competing in this past
Olympiad and uh it initially it wasn't
clear how it would work out I mean I
know Brian Doyle he at the time he was
the handling the U.S Chess Federation
side and it was very complicated I think
we found out our hotel like four days
before the Olympiad and some of the
players like vegan she got her visa like
you know like five days before she left
so there's a lot of stress but once we
arrived in Chennai the the Indians were
incredibly you know gracious very
generous hosts uh and you know they did
everything they could to make us
comfortable I'd say that the only two
things that they couldn't control were
the weather and covet and uh in the case
of uh the weather it was just really
really hot I mean it was like 90 degrees
which all right for St Louis that's not
so bad but yeah but but it seemed like
it was I thought you know St Louis can
get pretty humid but this was like on
another level uh but of course it all
teams you know you know encountered this
heat it wasn't just our team that did
the other other thing was covid and that
was kind of a mixed bag because on the
one hand you have all these chess
players that desperately want to
come together and to play in the
Olympiad such a special event but on the
other hand you know uh in India they
were having a pretty serious outbreak in
the southern part of India and you know
just in general olympiads where players
come from all over the world usually
somewhere in the world it's like you
know flu season or what have you and so
the net result was that there were a
fair number of players that were sick on
our team that was a big challenge it was
a big Challenge and this Olympiad it
definitely was if you look at our
lineups pretty much the first half of
the term and I thought it made sense you
know everybody gets one free day but the
second half of the tournament for the
most part
it was like who is healthy because you
only have one reserved player and Lavone
in particular he was really uh I mean he
couldn't play the last little two rounds
and and arguably he shouldn't have
played before that he just he wanted to
play he wanted to help the team but he
just was really really sick difficult
moments in India but let's talk about
your talk uh that is happening on uh
Thursday if I'm not mistaken and we do
have some highlights and some graphics
for you
takeaways for a Tuesday in fact uh well
I would say that uh
one thing that should be interesting for
this lecture for even the most die-hard
Bobby Fisher's fan is there'll be some
photos that they won't have seen of him
before so I think that would be one
thing that would be special I think
another thing that will be uh unique is
there'll be a number of photos of Boris
basket especially from earlier in his
career that will be
shown and you know in this match the 72
match
you know Fisher usually always gets you
know front and center and spaski's kind
of the you know the gentleman but but he
was the good loser you know The Whipping
Boy but he behaved so nobly uh but in
this particular case uh there will be
also a lot of attention on on spaski and
I think that that's only fair because he
had an incredible run from like about
1964 to 1972 where he you know won the
ozone in 64 and he went through the
candidates twice he lost his first world
championship match by The Narrows of
margins to petrosion and then managed to
defeat him so that will uh be brought up
and oh by the way I I have to say this
is one of my favorite Parts about the
current show in St Louis those uh
yeah it's the furniture from uh uh Jack
Collins apartment and it's I mean the
real chairs that Bobby and Lombardi and
uh Ray Weinstein all those guys would
sit on when they would play and analyze
with Collins and that's the actual chess
pieces that they actually used and you
know today young players they they gain
all their information playing on the
internet and and you know using chess
engines but for Bobby his uh
you know explosive growth occurred when
he visited Collins for you know the
better part of like six hours every day
uh for for that time period and just you
know
analyzed with him played with him people
would wander into the apartment you know
that were fellow chess players and they
look at the the games they had played
and it was kind of a who's who of New
York chess and that kind of a total
immersion was what really helped Bobby
you know make that leap from you know
like an expert to 2600 feet a candidate
level player John thank you very much uh
and I'm looking forward to it I will be
there tomorrow to watch the lecture I'm
really looking forward to it thank you
very much for joining us show thank you
thank you John thank you so much
definitely be joining as well me too me
too it's really really fun by the way